hey everybody we made it into double
digits it's episode 10 of wild ride with
steve-o and out of respect for what's
going on in our country we are donating
100% of the money generated by this
episode to the n-double-a-cp
empowerment fund to be clear the
n-double a-c-p is an organization at the
forefront of the movement to build
political power and ensure the
well-being of communities of color and
that means all the money paid by the
sponsors as well as all of the YouTube
Adsense revenue receive will all be
donated to that and I think every single
podcast leading up to this I've made it
clear what a huge fan of the UFC I am
and this weekend we've got UFC 250
Amanda Nunez and Felicia Spencer and I
had the distinct honor of talking to
Dana White about it so let's get into it
folks ladies and gentlemen it is Dana
White yeah what's up guys what's up how
are you the world seems to be crumbling
around us it's upsetting an awful time
and the one thing that I really have to
look forward to is the [ __ ] fight so
thank you for that man thank you I love
your fight Island sure do every time
every after fight press conference every
just everything you do you do so well
and it's just such an honor to have you
on here so Thank You Man
thanks brother I really appreciate that
it means a lot thank you we always look
at each other after you say something
like this Dana why it's just the [ __ ]
man
unapologetic the most completely
confident everything you do and I love
it
so first question that I want to ask you
is if say hypothetically this is a new
van not the one that I had you in this
is a more involved RV set up and if I
were to jump behind the wheel and drive
this sucker to Vegas that that's where
we've got in UFC 250 this weekend right
and the apex right if I drove out there
is there some little [ __ ] nurse or
doctor that I could go to and get like a
swab up my nose and if I pass the Cova
test would I be allowed to be a
spectator even if I worked as your
assistants assistant that's a good
question
let me let me let me let me figure that
out so what we've done is here and here
in Nevada is try to limit the amount of
people that are inside the arena even
though they're all tested and you know
keep them separated in social distance
then whatever the hell else is going on
here and you know so let me see I would
love to have you there if I think we can
pull that off I mean admittedly I would
be non-essential so it makes sense that
I wouldn't be allowed but I'll tell you
dude I would take a cotton swab corvid
test down my dick hole to be there
hey how [ __ ] up is that if we're
calling people non-essential now I've
got my fiancee she is every bit as much
of UFC fan as I am and her new way of
demanding sex from me as she says I'm
gonna need some ground and pound it's
safe to say that I get more excited for
fights based on disliking a fighter then
is that like a common thing you notice
yeah like you have to be invested in a
fight one way or and
their weather you know whatever the
storyline is in the fight or whether you
want a guy to win or lose or it's it's
all about investment it's it's what
makes the whole fight fun whether you
bet on them or bet against them or
whatever it is right I mean do I enjoy
just disliking colby covington so much
he's very good he's very good at it I
mean it's just weird
God did so and and and as you know I do
not miss a fight like I've watched every
early prelim every prelim I got no
matter what's awesome and as you also
know me of course I'm not on tour now
but but for the most part on Saturday
nights I would be like performing in a
comedy club or a theater so I would miss
the fights and then I come back to my
room and I turn on them you know I open
up yes pn+ and and and I would you would
get these messages from me just raging
oh my god to see the fights and then
they've given away the outcome of the
fight on the thumbnail like that ESPN
Plus would show the thumbnail which I
have to click on to watch the fight and
it's a guy like in victory with his arms
up it's like it was a big problem first
we had to fix that we had to fix that
when we first started with those guys
my question is am I responsible for
getting that fixed yeah I think that was
you wasn't it that reached out to me and
said you [ __ ] ruining the fight
that's right I forgot about that but
right that was you that's the steve-o
rule I forgot about that you [ __ ] hit
me up on that you were all pissed off
and yeah and I reached out the ESPN and
they fixed them that's right yeah you
told me you said just hit up yes PN and
the number two at Disney you know what's
funny about that too that you end up you
know I was such a I was such a huge fan
of jackass you know the night that that
that I think it was the second jackass
came I was either 1 or 2 I can't
remember but we're we were we had a
fight in Southern California and I
literally went down to the movie theater
and and they cuz I wanted to see it in
the theater the opening night and the
movie theater people let me go in with
my crew before they open the theater and
that we got our seats and sat in there
and then the place came in and filled in
after we sold out the movie was sold out
it was it was packed but I was a huge
and I don't know if you ever saw like
one of the weigh-ins I wore a dick house
shirt did you ever see that I did I've
really been like a die-hard you have
seed man since like Ronda Rousey came in
to the picture you know when I wore that
shirt at the thing Knoxville hit me up
after that after that weigh-in dad
and how huge is the UFC right now be
like for example on this podcast and
this is episode 10 we're so excited
about it but we had Demi Lovato huge UFC
Fan you know we were talking about she
was saying how she got a text from you
and she didn't know who said who is this
it's Dana White she was like oh [ __ ] you
know we did Ronda Rousey on here she
could not love you more I mean it was
Scott asked her who's the cooler boss
Vince McMahon or Dana White and she just
could not be stopped just gushing about
how much of a just a mentor a personal
friend like how much she loves you and
you know contrary to popular belief I
have pretty good relationship with most
of the guys you can't get along with
everybody all the time I got 600 and
something alpha males and females so
eventually something's going to [ __ ]
blow but you know I have a pretty good
relationship with everybody I try
anyway.you the best again we had Shaq on
Shaq's a huge fan of the UFC yeah
everybody's a huge fan of the UFC are
you are you in the war room right now is
that what they call it yeah yeah we're
in the war
and then you're announcing you're making
some fights tomorrow or on Tuesdays or
the fight that's exactly right
Tuesday is matchmaking meeting and we
make fights on Tuesdays you can't give
us any hands on on who you got coming up
literally don't have anything going on
right now oh yeah
Dana White's about to reveal the inner
workings of the War Room and I'm about
to reveal the inner workings of my
[ __ ] and I'm very serious about this
because the way that we poop in America
is messed up because we're sitting like
in a way that we're not naturally
supposed to sit which is why I use
squatty potty you see it gets your knees
up this is the position that we were
intended to poop in like in the eastern
hemisphere they don't sit on a toilet
they poop into a hole in the ground I'm
telling you I use squatty potty and I'm
so serious about it that when I'm
staying in a hotel and I don't have one
with me I unplugged the microwave and I
put it in front of the toilet because
[ __ ] microwaves and [ __ ] the hotel for
not having a squatty potty not only if
you go to squatty potty dot-com / devo
will you get 20% off your order
they're picking five of the people who
order squatty potty's to give an extra
one to which i am right now gonna sign
that's right five lucky people who order
from squatty potty dot-com / devo will
not only get 20% off their order but
will get an extra squatty potty signed
by me do this for your health man I'm
serious I've been doing it for six years
my poops are considerably more complete
quick and healthy all right
last time I was in here I gave some away
oh [ __ ] yeah that would oh yeah so this
hold on let me let me [ __ ] with this no
no you stay where you are
get over here this is the guy
[Music]
just so you know he's been out for a
while and he's finally back this is like
his who's your first day back this is
the second day back to work so he's in
here straightening [ __ ] out but this is
the guy with the greatest [ __ ]
handwriting okay look at this
handwriting this kid has wow I dig it
holy [ __ ] right so he's in here updating
this thing right now what's that say
Frankie Edgar's on his last fight these
are all guys whose contracts are coming
up and we have to renew or whatever but
yeah I'll give you something here so
he's got to write 600 names on that
board yeah yeah yeah yeah this this guy
comes in and kills it he writes on every
single wall and replaces all the slides
for the fights that are coming up but we
have right now July 25th is that good
July 25th Robert Whittaker Georgia still
okay that's a good one the co-main event
is Shogun hula versus little nog and I
don't know if those fights are done yet
but that they're what's on the board
right now it's being placed up here and
we'll go through it tomorrow and and see
what I like what I want to keep what I
want to switch um that's how it works
and that stills only second fight at
middleweight went up from welterweights
middleweight and he called out Izzy and
Izzy was like no obviously so does that
mean where's it gonna be because they're
both we don't have well if it's if it's
July 25th it's fight island oh my god
that's I you should ask to go to that
one instead of the APEC so what the [ __ ]
is going on with Jon Jones
I mean I love the guy that you know the
last two times I went to Albuquerque he
came to my show I had the the venue
managers to come to the the green room
and say hey John Jones is here and he's
wondering would it be okay if he could
come in and say hi and I was like what
holy [ __ ] of course he can come in and
say hi the sweetest dude you know like
so did you see him walking you see him
walking down the streets last night now
occurred you taking spray-paint cans is
badass
those kids [ __ ] their pants for sure I
think maybe I should just send UFC
fighters out in the streets and stop
this [ __ ] yeah Chuck Liddell in
Huntington but I just like it's it's so
in Chael Sonnen I really enjoy his
YouTube channel his commentary on the
UFC is just so articulate it's so just
right on point
and ya know he knows what he's talking
about and listen these these are the
kind of things that happen though you
know what I mean at the end of the day
everybody wants more money everybody
wants more money it's human nature you
know what I mean you ask any of the
people they're in here working right now
they all want more money everybody needs
more money it's it's just it's it's you
know you never talk to somebody and say
you get paid enough they're like you
know what I actually think I'm paid too
much I think these guys are overpaying
me it's it's it's amazing I'm never
gonna hear that and you know I think
John Jones is looking at you know he's
looking down the barrel of the end of
his career and and and you know he wants
to make as much money as he possibly can
sure and I don't fault them for that I
don't I don't ever ever blame a guy for
wanting to make more money it's it's
it's it's completely normal so I see how
sometimes we have these beefs but let me
put it to you this way you know have
whether it's Henry cejudo
or it's John Jones right do either one
of you have enough money to [ __ ]
retire right now and just say [ __ ] it
I'm done I'm pissed off and that's it
I'm never gonna [ __ ] work again as
long as I live yeah I wouldn't want to
put it to the test
and that go [ __ ] crazy if I couldn't
work for the rest of my life like I have
to do something these guys have the
money to retire may have the money to
say [ __ ] it you know what I'm pissed off
and I'm not happy and I'm not gonna work
anymore I mean I think I think that
you're a prime example of somebody who
has plenty of money to retire and just
loves his job I mean [ __ ] that [ __ ] the
pandemic gave you gave you a glimpse of
what retirement would be like and the
rest of your life would be a [ __ ]
pandemic I'm not good with that I'm I I
love what I do I love this sport I love
going to work every day and yeah about
fight Island we're gonna find out about
fight island but first I'm gonna tell
you about a war I've been waging for
years against nose and ear hair and the
sad truth is I was losing hopelessly
until very recently
why because I travelled with a nose hair
trimmer that looks like a comb like that
right okay that's all you're gonna do
what that thing has come it's useless
god I couldn't cut anything and thank
God manscaped has solved the problem
absolutely definitively with the weed
whacker this is a new product alert
folks okay we're not combing nose hair
anymore
we are annihilating it with this out
you know I demonstrate it but it works
so well there's nothing in there because
the weed whacker works so well oh man
and you know we're talking to Dana way
here manscaped who makes the weed
whacker totally sponsors the UFC you
think that these fighters are gonna get
caught running around ungroomed I mean
they're trying to make weight they don't
have time for extra hair and damn well
not in their nose and ears so good news
you go to manscape calm and yeah enter
the promo code steve-o what do you get
you get 20% off your whole order and
free shipping again that is 20% off your
whole order and free shipping when you
use the promo code steve-o at manscaped
dot-com get this thing because I'm
telling you when girls see hair coming
out of your nose and especially your
ears they'd sooner barf then get
intimate with you
so yeah Thank You manscaped god I needed
this years ago all right
back to this show is it the same island
that you had set up when it was gonna be
UFC 249 and then you said that ESPN said
hey look we need you to back off of this
yes it is but 249 wasn't supposed to be
on the island then it was that was going
to be in California okay
yeah when ESPN asked me not to do that
fight that was California got it we were
gonna go to an Indian Reservation out
there nice okay the sizes of the Octagon
and they had a question about that yeah
why is that octagon in the apex five
feet smaller in diameter than when it's
in an arena because it's a smaller venue
so we built a smaller octagon which we
used to do fights at the palms or the
Hard Rock we would use a smaller octagon
when you go into you know the t-mobile
Arena right you need a bigger octagon
the thing will look like [ __ ] in there
with a small octagon so that's why we
built the smaller one we actually did we
had our really smart kids that work here
pull some numbers on finishes inside the
Octagon there's no difference okay so
there's a difference between the size of
the Octagon
okay got it okay because I've been
noticing from just the the apex you know
one event a lot of good things being
said about the smaller octagon right we
were just just in Florida we're just in
Florida in every fight that week was
great right in the big octagon right
these [ __ ] media guys are so hard up
for [ __ ] to write right now they're
writing about anything
though the main [ __ ] most of what you
read is [ __ ] these guys are all full
of [ __ ]
all the media they're all
[ __ ] you can't believe anything you
[ __ ] read anymore I mean I saw where
you went up what was it that was at the
New York Times you said this guy found
that he wrote an article about the UFC
and all of a sudden he got all kinds of
views on it or whatever and so now he's
writing UFC [ __ ] all over the place
nobody's talking about and the thing is
you know and I know everybody thinks
that this is a [ __ ] dig but it's not
a dig this is the truth you know it I
know it and [ __ ] everybody knows it
one of the biggest problems is you know
the weakest people on [ __ ] earth
cover the toughest sport on earth so
when these guys come up with all the
stupid [ __ ] that they say or whatever it
is it's like what would you expect them
to say you know what I mean if you took
all the [ __ ] biggest wimps on the
planet and you put them all in a room
together right the media are wimps among
amongst wimps they are the [ __ ] always
there would be as [ __ ] guys in the
minute so what would you expect from
these people there's no better president
than it's been so it's been so great
like I remember because he followed me
on Instagram and I knew that we were
going to Chicago and then I'm like holy
[ __ ] dude there's this Romero
Whitaker fight you gave us front-row
tickets for that
unbelievable fight between Whitaker and
Romero in Chicago and we were sitting
the Pro Skater Chaz Ortiz and and then I
was like wow because I figured it out at
least in my view I don't want to bug you
for tickets to a fight that's happening
in LA or Anaheim or even Vegas for that
matter like Chicago was great because
there's not gonna be as many people
there and I flew me and my girl to
Dallas to watch till and Woodley got
where was where was Woodley you know two
nights ago well the thing is with
Woodley is that you know with the
Whitley's taking a lot of time
in his career and and even though the
guy is a [ __ ] physical specimen and
an incredible athlete 38 years old and
had almost two years off and you're
coming against these younger faster
[ __ ] savages like burns and you know
it eventually catches up with yet did
Woodley have to he had two camps for
that right I think so yeah I think so
yeah he didn't try to make an excuse he
said I was in phenomenal shape I was
ready for this fight and you know you
know this is a young man's game and
right and a lot of things and I'm a big
believer in ring Rus - do you notice it
do you notice a difference in fighters
when like when when they're when they're
fresh and they're in they're new and
they come out and they're just doing it
for the love of fighting and they're
[ __ ] crushing in there like you know
all I want to do is fight put me in and
then there's a transition where they're
like the money's got to be there 100%
and not just that I mean that listen if
you're selling and and and you're you're
going like this and bringing in money
you make [ __ ] [ __ ] loads of money the
sky's the limit for how much you can
make because you're a world champion you
share in the pay-per-view revenues right
so but the other thing that happens is
once a guy gets a lot of money and you
get on top and you become you know
you're the man that then everything you
do is is a threat to the lifestyle
you're living and what you have so you
know some of these guys handle it the
wrong way and fight less and want to
take less risk instead of diving in and
assuming all the risk at that time I
mean that's a Conor McGregor when you
talk about economy McGregor Ronda Rousey
you know those type of people were the
people that were like when they were on
top I don't give a [ __ ] I'll fight
everybody who do you want me to fight
I'll fight you know multiple times in a
[ __ ] three month period or whatever
the deal is and they made a lot of money
they made a lot of money they became
really famous and you know that that's
the way you got to go at it when you're
here and you're on top guns a [ __ ]
blazing and make as much money as you
possibly can oh yeah yeah speaking of
money you quick
when fighters say that like or you know
when you're not telling them what the
with her getting paid and what no it
went that one guy from the ESPN Radio
Dan a little bit hard yeah was giving
you a hard time that was so great when
you're like it's not your business right
but my question is like you know in even
Daniel Cormier said that he doesn't like
the fact that people know what he makes
and this and that but what about when
after a fight they post the purse what's
the difference between that and what
they're actually Manning so the reality
is here's the reality
none of these fighters none of these
fighters there's no contract they signed
they can they can say whatever they want
if they want to talk about their money
if they want to say how much they make a
fight how much they've made in their
career they can say that anytime they
want to they don't want to say that they
don't want anybody knowing how many they
made you know what these reporters so
these reporters come out and they try to
act like oh yeah yeah well you know this
is for the fighters whatever you're full
of [ __ ] reporters don't give a [ __ ]
about anybody but themselves reporters
want the story one on all I broke how
much this guy's making I got this and
that and the fighters know that the
fighters don't want anybody the fighters
do everything in their power to make
sure that the media and the fans and and
anybody else does not find out how much
money they make after a fight I feel
like there's been times where we googled
like what do people make and then it'll
come up like what people's purses were
think that's what Scott was asking is
that not that accurate are those
[ __ ] numbers I wouldn't say they're
[ __ ] numbers but there's lots of
other ways that the fighters make money
so that's part of what they made they
probably make a lot more than that I'll
sponsorship and whatever else not even
sponsorship just fighting about it their
sponsorship numbers numbers never come
out either I mean I don't even know what
they make in sponsorship that's you know
that's that's between them and they're
their team but you listen man if you
look at the at the fighters that I've
had here from Brock Lesnar to even even
somebody that hated each other like me
and Tito Ortiz
you know the Chuck Liddell's the the you
know the the guys that I publicly had
beefs with or whatever it might be
everybody sticks around man it's because
they make a lot of money here and it's
not like they don't make money in other
organizations because these other
organizations will throw ridiculous
amounts of money of guys and girls you
know to make them come there so ramie
Hey I mean cyber hasn't what you do
don't ever feel [ __ ] sorry for
somebody who's fighting over here
they're doing just fine right I think
SCI Burns had one fighter just one
fighter belt or right this was so
interesting when I first got that other
man and I saw that Tom Cruise calling
out Justin Bieber and I jumped in the
van
like it just so happened that you
invited me to the contender Syria zebra
I think Bieber called out through ya
Bieber cruise I was like I want to fight
Justin Bieber I couldn't ambarish to you
with that what a guy in the van I was
like we came out like set up a fight
between me and Bieber to get attention
and we were so nervous before we like
throw out some potential fights here
okay when I say them I love disliking
Kobe Covington I mean what are we gonna
do with Woodley he just didn't show up I
think that Covington and Woodley deserve
each other
Afghan drew if the new rankings came out
yet I think it would be probably drop
down a bit no they haven't
well if you look going into that fight
yeah you got who's mine who's the champ
yeah we got they were supposed to come
out they haven't yet but you
Woodley who just lost to two parents I
want to say is 12 here but he was number
six I can learn to ask are six right
just burns get Woodley or it spreads
c'mon you know burns a title shot when
Leon Edwards how does that work so you
got you got Colby Covington you got
Jorge Masvidal you got Leon Edwards and
now you know obviously you have Gilbert
burns right so all of those guys the
reality is we're gonna reach out
tomorrow I want to say who wants the
next fight who wants this fight who's
ready to go who wants to fight who's
mine if it's MASMA tall Edwards you know
or burns burns told me that night let's
turn this [ __ ] right around I'll fight
all right I Do's Mon now I'm ready you
know I think I love that kind of [ __ ]
when you're that guy when you're that
guy it's highly likely you're getting
that [ __ ] fight
god bless I love that now you recently
said in an interview that you've got
something bigger for Martha doll than
the title shot against is mine have you
already made up your mind Conor has
options I mean as balls in a place where
he's got some some fun options I don't
know I don't know if the Conor fight is
you know if I'm Connor I wait to see how
this gage he fight plays out you know
with Habib in September because I would
want another another shot at the title
right fighting guys like like Mavs but
all at 170 and these guys that are so
much bigger than him man it's it's just
what Connor Connor is Connor because
Connor takes risk right Connor is not
like I told you earlier Connor isn't a
guy that just sits around and waits and
isn't afraid to take risks so right I
mean with Mazda
honor was first mentioned you were quick
to say Mozilla was too big for Connor
for saying that right 100% and then
Connor five cowboy at 170 but Cowboys a
natural lightweight so that made sense
Connor versus a natural welterweight
maybe not not the best idea so I think
that you want Connor back down at
lightweight and you don't mind him
waiting until September to see what
happens with gage he and khabib yeah no
I don't mind that at all how many UFC
fighters text you after a fight like
Dana put me in like your phone must blow
the [ __ ] up yeah it does it does mine
mine and the matchmakers sacrificed are
blowing up just like the redheaded
stepchild is such a good fighter and
just somehow hasn't gotten the oh you
know he's definitely not the redheaded
stepchild I mean we were gonna do that
fight when the pandemic started we were
still going to go to London and do that
fight but you know the pandemic came and
you know we're deal with that [ __ ]
and he's definitely not the redheaded
stepchild we we see him he's ranked
number four in the world and you know
there's some fun options for him too
right okay and then we got gar Brandt
fighting this week yeah let's talk about
this week Santiago Bret is a super fun
fight Cory sand Hagan and Al Jermaine
sterling and then you got Milan and Sean
O'Malley Sean O'Malley came out the wall
this is his first fight back and his
first real big test you know what I mean
I'm so excited for it and relationship
with ESPN is just it is beautiful
couldn't be better man couldn't be
better and you know I think the fact
that these guys now see that we can
fight through a pandemic we can fight
through [ __ ] anything man I think we
have we have climbed a little higher on
the total
over at ESPN I think I think when we
first signed the deal we were like right
above cornhole okay find a much better
place on the totem pole over the ESPN
sure it's sad dude she's so great what
you've done for the sport like we're on
ESPN
like every celebrity in the world loves
it it's uh it's really rad and like I
said in the beginning man it's it's just
a tragic fucked-up sad time and you know
I'd like to just watch a little bit of
news and I feel myself just get bombed
and to be able to sit down and watch the
UFC man it means the [ __ ] world
thanks buddy I really appreciate a man
it means a lot thank you yeah hey dude
thank you so much for your time dude and
steve-o passes a CO vid test do I will
sweep the [ __ ] I'll be your janitor
I'll hit you back today I'll let you
know I appreciate that so much dude we
could not be bigger fans of you of the
UFC I do not ever miss a fight and thank
God we're getting this up in time to get
more people by and do you have c250
Nunez Spencer thanks brother I
appreciate it later boys in the UFC what
a rad dude and to fifty this weekend I'm
super psyched about it
everybody the street team thank you
you know what to do just what a crazy
time man what a crazy time loving
respect to everybody thank you so much